Emmanuel Sanders here on the Rich Eisen
show of the Denver Broncos how are you
Manuel I'm doing good over 2 i'm doing
better for you calling and how was last
night from your perspective man it was
definitely a great day to be a Bronco
you know for one you know my brother my
teammate a guy that's made me extremely
better as a football player and paid
many and breaking that record I was
definitely something special to be a
part of I mean I know that you know hey
you know obviously you love play this
game he's been a great ambassador out of
the game for him to achieve that uh you
know that achievement last night was
awesome to know that we had a great team
win in which we had a good san francisco
49ers to you come in it it's a sports
authority field and we played extremely
well on all cylinders office defense and
on special teams so it was a great day
how has he made you better how's he done
that oh well obviously um you know I
hear people you know talk on television
all the time about you know his physical
attributes but just how he approaches
the game and how he holds everyone up to
the highest standards because he holds
herself up to the highest Anderson you
know I come I come back home and I study
my butt off because I know that I don't
want to go into work and disappoint paid
I know that yet he'll probably two or
three more years uh just just this thing
and turns on his career I know that he
wants to go out he wants to win a super
bored I don't want to be too gotta hold
them back and I see made me want to play
for him and I and try to get him another
Super Bowl ring maybe one or two so with
that aspect of me plan for someone else
is definitely made me better what was
the first time where you realize that
where the realization I know that you've
been in Pittsburgh and and people when
you said something similar this earlier
in the season took it as a shot that you
took towards Ben Roethlisberger but
listen there's only one Peyton Manning s
number 5 10 can attest Emanuel so that
said when when was the first time where
you realize that as a Denver Bronco that
all the way that I've been
operating as an NFL player needs to
change well I wouldn't necessarily say
that the way that I operate needed to
change from a physical standpoint
because you know i love this game uh
just as much as peyton loves a game in
terms of how you know I go about my work
ethic from a physical standpoint but I
tell you what I Peyton from a mental
standpoint you definitely helped me
understand that you can have all the
physical tools in the world but this
game is played from from the neck above
and that's how he's helped me and it
definitely been in training camp because
in Pittsburgh of course I play busy
position which is outside receiver and I
stayed at the D position I only had to
know what the viewers here have but when
you plan an assistant with paid many you
got to know the whole content you got to
know what everyone has because you never
know where Adam GaSe will put you in
certain game situation so you got to
know the whole conceptual point of the
playing with you knowing what everyone
has it makes your game even more better
because you understand how to get guys
open get your teammates hope you
understand if the ball is coming to you
and when it's coming to you so that's
definitely helped me out from a mental
standpoint and your first touchdown of
the season came last night and it was
number 5 07 I guess so what did you get
to keep that I man yeah yeah definitely
get out of my first chest end of the
Denver Bronco it you know I'm just happy
to get it over with honor so yeah you
know up uh you know I've been having a
pretty good year in terms of you know
catching a lot of footballs and having a
decent amount of yards I always had that
egg off in the touchdown column in terms
of 08 defining you know get my first
touchdown get it out the winner you know
I just I just hope that is many more to
come 38 catches 514 yards and that
touchdown was there a competition
amongst the receiving corps to be the
one to catch the record breaker emmanuel
you know what rich i think the media
kind of talked about their record more
we ever talked nuttin locker I don't
remember a conversation even happening
no bugging any of us in the locker room
but it was conversations going on all
outside of that locker room but you know
what just like just like a page is not
gonna talk about records he's not going
to talk about anything that's individual
he's all about the team even when he
broke the record he he made it about the
team he understands this that battle
that was a great achievement but he
wants something even bigger than that
and that's a super bowl and so you know
we got a definite have a long journey
ahead of ourselves and hopefully many
more records all but you know we the one
thing that really is gone mad at in is
that would be hosting i lombardi trophy
hmm so you're you're saying it's just
dust in the paparazzi otherwise it was
unspoken amongst the Bronco yeah pretty
much haha really okay all except yeah
I'll accept that because it looked like
after Welker caught his to tie it he
pointed at the football and said to
Peyton like I'm keeping this that's what
it looked like to me from where I was
sitting last night I don't know you know
Wesson lesson take their both that good
buddies and they joke around with each
other a lot and they definitely a lot of
jokes all those oh you know what wes is
doing that night but we really didn't
talk about it too much in the lateral
well we were talking about her also
certainly at NFL network and the folks
at CBS because we're coming to your
house in three days we thought maybe
we'd have a chance to to see that record
ourselves instead we're just going to
see you and the San Diego Chargers
pretty play a huge football game to kick
off week number eight what are your
thoughts now that you enter this game
five and one in San Diego coming off of
that loss at home against the chase oh I
noticed an Diego don't want they don't
want to lose two back-to-back games
versus you know conference opponent and
I know they're gonna come into my Oh
sports authority field they're gonna
have their mind right in terms of one to
come here and play some good ball and
get a win in the wind category but you
know they're good team and we know that
we have go in in a in 12 days we got a
three-game stretch you know who plays 10
verses go
last night we got to san diego and then
we going into England away um we got
three tough games but in order for us to
get where we need to get we gotta be
tough opponents um just like we did last
night and hopefully we do on thursday
but we gotta continue to get better and
continuously preparing you know
hopefully it'll be a good game and I
know that Philip Rivers knows guys they
come in and they broke the same they
play the same kind of game we play they
actually run the similar type office
that we run no it's gonna be a good book
and at New England a place that I think
New England wanted you to call home
Emmanuel correct you know yeah yeah
definitely i had opportunity actually
been doing there patriot last year but
everything their fall then their fall in
place of course but you don't have to be
a bronco and you know focus on san diego
right now but obviously you know if we
can get you know this the chargers on
thursday night football go out in a
handle new england um you know in a
third game i think that that would be a
pretty good testament to you know what
type of team that we have you have to
change your twitter address because you
change numbers emmanuel yeah yeah yeah
and anyway for smart people that were
rich but I uh of course I was number 88
uh with the stillers and then I changed
the ten when i was when i came to
devaron i wanted to change it to 10 but
the moment that i posted a picture of
what jersey i was no clone some random
guy goes and just reach this woulda
feeding and tries to blackmail me in
order like within me that stuff if you
want i'm like wow that you know what
that i actually gave him a round of
applause because i would never think
that we create nothing the blackmail so
what happened well uh I just ended up
you know not just giving him what he
wanted and I just put underscore
underscore yeah yeah that's cat that can
be your friend but you know what
Emmanuel we have we have some Twitter
contacts we're this is well this is how
we work here on the show you call in the
day after a big milestone that you
supposedly didn't talk about you combo
all in right and we then help you let's
see if we can get rid of that underscore
and get this this this Twitter squatter
off of what you what do you want it to
be what do you want to know I wanted eat
finished and of course that's good but
we're going to work on that for you and
we're going to we're going and we'll get
the blue check mark to come with it too
that's the way we roll here on the show
but yeah okay Emmanuel thanks for
calling it the Rich Eisen show weekdays
at noon eastern on audience